fast unbemerkt entwickelt sich gerade
einen wettlauf in den weltraum als wir
gestern in einem kommentar vorgeworfen
wurde
ich würde beim vergleich spaceshuttle
dragon äpfel mit birnen vergleichen habe
ich mich ein wenig eingelesen und
erstaunliches festgestellt und dann kam
gestern noch die nachricht dass auch
indien zwei astronauten in den weltraum
schicken will ihnen aber gestern zum
ersten mal einen drei tonnen schweren
satelliten in den orbit gestartet wie
indien hätten wir dann bald vier
nationen die menschen ins all schicken
können 4 wie bitte jeder überwiegt bei
pixum zweiten sektion herzlich
willkommen
also erstmal was die ladekapazitäten von
space shuttle und dragon kapsel an gitta
zuschauer in limburg im grunde recht
aber auch nicht wehren brechen nur knapp
sechs tonnen befördern kann konnte das
spaceshuttle bis zu 24 anhalt tonnen
nutzlast transportieren allerdings hat
das space shuttle damit nicht die
internationale raumstation erreicht der
schub hat dafür nicht gelangt zur iss im
low earth orbit leo also in eine
niedrige erdumlaufbahn von rund 300
metern höhe konnten die shuttles
lediglich 16 4 tonnen bringen und da ist
die welt hinein trägerrakete von spacex
die auch die sorgen kaffeezeit es bringt
den space aber haushoch überlegen wie
kann 22 8 tonnen nutzlast in den neo
transportieren es hat sich einfach
gezeigt dass das eigengewicht eines
space shuttles von 119 im wahrsten sinne
des wortes ein klotz am bein ist und die
ladekapazität nur selten wirklich
benötigt wurde
kleinere kapseln bin da deutlich
günstiger und dann wurde ich neugierig
spacex hat nämlich eine weitere rakete
in planung die felton harry und deren
daten würden absolut beeindruckend wie
immer noch nicht so leistungsfähig wie
die natur und 5 rakete des
apollo-programms aber es geht langsam
wieder in diese richtung und das zu
deutlich reduzierten kosten während die
saturn fünf pakete 50 tonnen zum mond
schicken konnte ist die falcon heavy
immerhin in der lage knapp 64 tonnen zur
iss zu transportieren
wie wäre also in der lage große module
wie für eine raumstation in den low
earth orbit leo zu transportieren
in den geostationären orbit leo in
36.000 kilometern höhe immerhin noch
knapp 27 tonnen
und jetzt kommt's zum mars knapp 17 das
sind absolut beachtliche werte und sie
sagen eine menge über die zukunftspläne
von basic voraus und mit dem flug von
astronauten im weltall wird ja nächstes
jahr im mai wieder begonnen darüber
hatten wir ja im letzten video berechnet
damit wären die usa wieder im club aber
auch drei weiteren aktionen neben den
usa wollen oder schicken bereits
astronauten oder wie in china reißt kein
konnten ins all
achtung hier ein kleiner versteckte
hinweise satz also kurz zu ihnen die hat
man mit der gs lvm cup
die einst endlich eine trägerrakete die
menschen ins all transportieren kann
endlich muss man sagen denn zahlreiche
starts zuvor gingen schief und die
raketen flogen nicht ins all sondern in
den indischen ozean
weshalb die abkürzung aufhört seine
rally fila dem vehikel kurz generell
wegen des gefährts stand jetzt aber ist
der start eines mehr als drei tonnen
schweren satelliten gelungen innen ist
im wettlauf mit dabei russland ist
natürlich weiter im rennen und hat mit
dem focus und focus programm
der leistungsfähige und vor allem
kostengünstige systeme
denn das wird für die weiterentwicklung
der raumfahrt entscheidend sein
kostensenkung werden hier dazu führen
dass immer mehr möglich wird und eher
preiswerte charakteren staat werden
einen flug zum mars ermöglichen den
ansonsten kein land finanzieren könnte
aber kommen wir zum kleinen hinweis
gerade taikonauten wenn ihr am besten
bekommen von der rasanten entwicklung in
china kaum etwas mit und jetzt die bombe
china verfügt bereits über ein weltraum
labor in dem im letzten jahr 2000 einen
monat experimente durchführten wie
dienen und jetzt kommt s bombe zwei zur
vorbereitung einer eigenen raumstation
und jetzt nochmal achtung bombe drei die
bereits 2022 also in fünf jahre dienst
aufnehmen und diese aufenthalt im
weltraum labor im letzten jahr war erst
der sechste raumflug der schnee gelegen
ein wahnsinns tempo vor und werden dann
wenn sie an der iss beteiligten ländern
nicht noch eine idee haben ab spätestens
2028 die einzige raumstation im orbit
und hätten damit die chance den westen
technologisch abzuhängen ob sie aber
jemanden schlag mit ich bin sehr sehr
sehr gespannt wie dieser wettlauf
weitergeht wird der westen hier von
china abgehängt und kann die zukunft
nicht mehr weltraumforschung und auch
die militärstrategen schauen ganz
gebannt nach asien sie fürchten die
vormacht china dem weltraum mit der sie
im kriegsfall schnell die oberhand über
den erdorbit und die satelliten dort
gewinnen könnten zwar sehen die chinesen
bringen ähnlich
naja dann schauen wir mal was ich in der
zukunft tut der wettlauf ins weltall
scheint jedenfalls sehr spannend zu
werden ich halte euch dazu natürlich
hier auf dem laufenden wenn ihr nicht
verpassen wollte das wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf
die glocke dann werdet ihr auch über
jedes video informiert hier geht es
weiter mit dem video über
weltraumtourismus geht es jetzt doch
schon los und ich sage bis dann bleibt